اصدر نائب رئيس مجلس السياده السوداني
مالك عقار امرا للفرقه الرابعه مشا بالدما
ازين باقليم النيل الازرق بالتقدم نحو
مدينه ود مدني التي تسيطر عليها قوات
الدعم السريع واكد عقار ان المؤسسه
العسكريه متماسكه ويجب الحفاظ
عليها انا مؤكد واكد لكم
انصب وما تقوموا في
الزوم في
في
بدن وشان العيال عشان العيال هنا ينوم
عيال بره هنا في الدمازين وفي سج ياخذوا
راحتهم انتش نوم في مدن ياخ راحته ن احنا
مصلحتنا كلنا كان في النيل ازرق وكان في
دارفور وكين ان السودان ده يكون دوله
واحده لانه لو قطع بعدين ما في حاجه
بيجمعنا لازم يجمعنا دوله اسمه سودان لازم
نكون شغالين لوحده السودان والمؤسسه
العسكريه دي دي المؤسسه الوحيده اللي لسه
مؤسسه متماسكه فيها تنوعات
السودان